das könnte auch die versorgung mit
lebensmittel auf der erde
revolutionieren forschungsteams weltweit
arbeiten mit hochdruck daran im weltall
gemüse anzubauen
doch es gibt einige herausforderungen
doch mittlerweile scheint ein
gewächshaus auf dem mars oder mond
durchaus realistisch und schon jetzt
weiß die forschung welcher boden von
welchem planeten bzw mond sich am besten
eigenen klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocken und dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen übrigens
gibt's clixoom jetzt auch als podcast
der link zum spotify oder apple ist
unten in der video beschreibung also für
täglich was auf die ohren wenn ihr
unterwegs seid also unbedingt drauf
klicken
herzlich willkommen also noch mal fest
steht wenn wir menschen auf mond oder
mars siedeln wollen brauchen wir dort
auch nahrung entweder eingeflogen was
umfasst sich teuer wäre oder aber
praktischerweise direkt vor ort
kultiviert möglich wurde das durch ein
in sich geschlossenes gewächshaus das
auch im weltraum für sichere ernten
sorgen könnte
doch nicht nur im all sondern auch in
klimatisch ungünstigen regionen der erde
würde ein solches in sich geschlossenes
zuwächse aus den anbau von nutzpflanzen
möglich machen und das ist nicht nur
aufgrund der zunehmenden weltbevölkerung
sondern auch wegen des klimawandels eine
idee die fachleute so schnell wie
möglich umsetzen wollen mit dabei ist
unter anderem das deutsche zentrum für
luft- und raumfahrt dlr und zwar mit dem
projekt ideen ss hierbei handelt es sich
tatsächlich um ein modell gewächshaus
der zukunft das ein ganzes jahr lang in
der antarktis auf seinen ernteertrag
getestet wurde und zwar mit erfolg
innerhalb eines jahres konnten insgesamt
achtung 117 kilogramm salat 46 kilo
tomaten 67 kilo gurken 19 kilo kohlrabi
15 kilo kräuter und acht kilo radieschen
geerntet werden
betrieben wurde das iss gewächshaus an
der sogenannten neumayer station 3 und
zwar unter antarktischen
extrembedingungen dazu der
wissenschaftler daniel schubert die
antarktis mit ihren extremen
klimatischen bedingungen mit bis zu
minus 40 grad bietet ein optimales test
umfeld das gewächshaus besteht aus einem
high tech container der eine anbaufläche
von 310 quadratmetern bietet also
achtung dieses gemüse ist innerhalb
eines jahres auf 13 quadratmeter
gewachsen
der absolute wahnsinn in den
herrschenden 21 grad celsius und 65
prozent relative luftfeuchte die
pflanzen wachsen hier ohne erde
tageslicht und pestizide
das forschungsteam konnte von bremen aus
beobachten was im gewächshaus passiert
kameras und monitore zeigen nicht nur
den sauerstoff und kohlendioxid gehalt
an sondern auch die temperaturen
luftfeuchtigkeit computer gesteuert
wurden die wurzeln der pflanzen mit
einer nährstofflösung besprüht und zwar
alle fünf minuten
zudem bekam sie extra kohlendioxid und
licht und all das sorgte dafür dass die
pflanzen schneller wuchsen als unter
normalen bedingungen ähnlich soll das
szenario dann auch auf der ss oder bei
einer echten raumfahrt mission aussehen
von der erde aus könnte die pflanzen
aufzug bereits gestartet werden wenn die
astronautin astronauten sich noch auf
dem weg befinden dazu deine schubert vom
dlr
wenn die astronauten am mars ankommen
soll das gewächshaus schott in voller
blüte stehen bzw
es würde schon die ersten früchte oder
eben gemüse tragen ein weiteres
experiment um gewächshäuser im weltraum
zu realisieren basiert auf parabelflügen
so sollen analysiert werden wie pflanzen
mit der erdanziehung umgehen und ob sie
ohne überhaupt gedeihen können klar ist
dass fanden sich nicht nur am licht
orientieren sondern auch an der
schwerkraft in der fachsprache ist von
grafik tropisch muss die rede als
modellpflanze für solche ergebnisse
eignet sich wohl vor allem die
ackerschmalwand pflanze auch als arab
die pose bekannt hier werden spannende
ergebnis erwartet denn die pflanze hat
im laufe ihrer evolution keine
schwebezustand kennengelernt untersucht
wird welche molekularen prozesse in der
schwerelosigkeit gesteuert werden diese
erkenntnisse können hinweise auf den
einfluss der schwerkraft liefern die
pflanzen werden dazu unter anderem
parabelflügen ausgesetzt im labor können
dann mit hilfe von massenspektrometer
signal prozesse aufgespürt werden klar
ist jedenfalls dass der anbau von
pflanzen im weltall die bemannte
raumfahrt weit nach vorne bringen würde
nicht nur um die quote somit mit
vitaminreichen lebensmitteln zu
versorgen auch als sauerstoff
produzenten ja wäre das gefragt das
deutsche zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
jedenfalls hat
das ziel ein gewächshaus für den mond zu
entwerfen entstehen könnte das zunächst
in einem raumfahrt module auch ein
niederländisches forschungsteam hat sich
mit der landwirtschaft einmal
beschäftigt in dem projekt fordert nun
konnten die fachleute herausfinden dass
regenwürmer tatsächlich im simulierten
mars boden überleben eigentlich wollte
das forschungsteam in den experimenten
herausfinden inwieweit rucola auf ihrem
maß ähnlichen boden heranwächst wurde
kann material aus hawaii kam von der
nasa und sollte die mars erde simulieren
das niederländische forschungsteam gab
noch gülle und ausgewachsene regenwürmer
hinzu und die überraschung ließ sich
erst gegen ende des experiments blicken
zwei junge regenwürmer langweilig
dagegen erscheint das weitere ergebnis
des versuchsaufbaus die gülle hat das
wachstum des rucola stimuliert wen
wundert's denn ja auch wenn die
entdeckung der beiden jungen regenwürmer
erst einmal banal erscheint auf dem
zweiten blick ist sie umso
überraschender und tatsächlich auch
spektakulär denn es handelt sich wohl um
die nachkommen der eingangs eingesetzten
regenwürmer das heißt also dass die
beiden jungen würmer in der mars
ähnlichen erde geboren sind und diese
tiere sind ausschlaggebend für ein
nachhaltig aufgebautes geschlossenes
ökosystem und das wiederum ist eine
voraussetzung dafür dass menschen auf
dem mars leben und sich ernähren können
schon seit 2013 forschen die
niederländer zu diesem themengebiet
unter anderem analysieren sie welche
gemüsesorten sich für einen anbau auf
mond oder mars anbieten beispielsweise
kresse kartoffeln oder eben rucola und
ihre ergebnisse sind vielversprechend
sowohl auf dem mars als auch auf dem
mond ähnlichen boden lassen sich
pflanzen züchten 50 tage lang kommen die
pflanzen bestenfalls ohne zugabe von
nährstoffen aus interessant ist aber
auch dass der simulierte mars boden den
anforderungen der pflanzen besser nach
kommt als der simulierte mond posen
vielleicht liegt es daran dass es auf
dem mars schon mal leben gab der boden
also grundsätzlich besser für leben
geeignet ist kommt das leben vom mars
anklicken anschauen und us comics tv
abonnieren mega cola kanal
ich liebe ihn bis dann bleibt dran